[Music]
don't expect a white tt cut of thor love
and thunder anytime soon why were some
fans disappointed at notable character
absences and a suspicious lack of god
butchering and how many death fake outs
are too much these are the thor love and
thunder moments that really upset fans
spoilers ahead
christian bale is gore the godbutcher
and thor 11 thunder looks pretty cool
all things considered however there were
some fans who were very vocally upset
that he doesn't really look like his
comic book counterpart while bale's
portrayal of the complicated villain has
been largely well received it makes
sense why some fans would be upset while
comic book movies have been notorious in
the past for being lacks about how they
adapted characters backstories and looks
modern comic book movies have for the
most part been much more faithful
director taika waititi said in an
interview with ign that he expected that
fans would think a more comics accurate
gore looked like voldemort after all his
pale bald noseless comic design does
emulate the fantasy villain quite a bit
however at the end of the day the gore
in love and thunder is still undeniably
gore and why tt felt that the
character's story was far more important
than any visual similarities to other
fictional villains
thor loving thunder is a fun film but it
also touches on some dark moments and
themes after all the main villain is
literally named gore the godbutcher
which sounds like the name of a
norwegian black metal band as such fans
expected to see more intense mature
scenes some of which were apparently
left on the cutting room floor
in an interview with ign christian bale
talked about one brutal sequence that
never made it into the film bale said
gore is a highly religious character at
the beginning with tattoos displaying
his piousness and then he becomes
disillusioned with that and then
literally just mutilates himself to get
rid of that it was perhaps a little bit
too extreme to be included in the film
but there was a lot of wonderful stuff
that we shot great scenes get deleted
for a variety of reasons and it sounds
like this one was cut to make the film
more broadly appealing as bale said in
the same interview some things can work
some things don't and we want this to be
a family film my kids love it let's
bring the rainbow
the morally ambiguous loki is a fan
favorites in the mcu for a reason loki
is thor's adopted evil brother and
eventual arch-nemesis essentially the
joker to thor's batman of course his
true nature and morality became much
more fluid over the years much like the
mythical norse god with whom he shares
his name loki made his live-action
feature film debut in 2011's thor and
has been in every single thor feature up
until now he's also the star of his own
popular disney plus show loki it's safe
to say that fans like to see as much
loki as the mcu is willing to showcase
unfortunately it makes sense that loki
is absent from the most recent thor film
as there's really no room for him in the
already crowded narrative not to mention
he's currently considered dead to
everyone in the current universe still
his absence was always going to upset
fans no matter what i guess i'll just
have to go it alone
like i've always done
sif played by actress jamie alexander
was a familiar face in the first two
thor films she was originally part of
thor's group of powerful asgardian
warriors who assisted him in fighting
off frost giants and loki and thor those
same warriors later helped bring peace
to the universe after the destruction of
the bifrost in thor the dark world
unfortunately she was mostly out of the
picture after that to the vocal
disappointment of some fans as such it
was great seeing her again in thor love
and thunder sadly we don't get to see
her fight or really do anything cool
instead we see her already defeated
after having her arm cut off by gore the
godbutcher beyond that we also find out
that she was only left alive by gore so
that she could give thor a warning
ultimately it's disappointing that thor
love and thunder couldn't find a more
interesting role for sit to play
fans speculated that the fan favorite
comics character beta ray bill would
appear in thor love and thunder
unfortunately beta ray bill didn't show
up at all not even as an easter egg as
he did in thor ragnarok for those who
don't know beta ray bill made his comic
book debut in 1983's thor number 337
beta ray bill was an alien warrior who
despite his extremely monstrous
appearance was actually an honorable and
brave hero one who was worthy enough to
be able to wield mjolnir the reason why
beta ray bill is so popular is not just
because he was one of the first
characters besides thor to wield mjolnir
in the marvel universe he also
contributed to the creation of the comic
book version of stormbreaker hopefully
the mcu can find a way to fit him in the
next solo thor adventure next time baby
the ending of avengers end game implied
that there'd be a lot of guardians of
the galaxy screen time in the sequel
some fans even referred to the potential
sequel as asgardians of the galaxy sure
that title was never confirmed but that
just goes to show how the possibility of
a true guardian to the galaxy and thor
team up had some fans pretty excited to
be fair the entire first part of the
movie is an extended montage of thor
working with the famous guardians team
still fans who did want more guardians
of the galaxy screen time were
undoubtedly a bit disappointed
especially since early trailers implied
they'd potentially be a bigger part of
the plot
the death of jane foster aka the mighty
thor is one of those scenes that was
purposely meant to upset audiences after
all portman's portrayal of the new thor
was charming and fun and it's sad when
any fan favorite character sacrifices
themselves to save the day what's even
more upsetting is that she begins the
movie suffering from a cancer diagnosis
while mjolnir seemingly heals her and
makes her a literal god it's also what's
stopping her from healing while in human
form this means that anytime she's out
superheroine with thor is mighty thor
she's getting closer and closer to death
every time she lets go of the hammer her
final sacrifice is extremely well done
with both portman and hemsworth selling
the sadness and beauty of her ultimate
heroic sacrifice still that didn't stop
some fans from complaining
[Music]
korg the lovable cronin is at one point
seemingly killed to the surprise of thor
and his friends this happens while the
gang heads to omnipotent city where the
different gods of the universe
congregate the heroes are going there to
try and warn zeus about gore the god
butcher and request the gods help in
defeating him however zeus doesn't like
being ordered around and would prefer to
stay hidden in omnipotent city which
causes a fight between the asgardians
and zeus during the attack zeus blasts
korg with his famous lightning bolt
which causes him to explode the death
was upsetting for fans who thought that
the film killed off such a lovable
character luckily korg comes back to
life as apparently cronins just need
their heads to survive
speaking of zeus at the end of that
fight thor sends one of zeus's lightning
bolts straight back into the olympian's
chest seemingly killing him this allows
our heroes to escape from the gods
omnipotent city with his weapon in tow
however at the end of the film during
the post-credits scene it's revealed
that like porg zeus actually survived
the attack he talks about how the people
used to worship gods but now call for
superheroes in times of need instead we
then see that he's talking to his son
hercules who himself is a lesser known
superhero in the marvel universe
unfortunately zeus's death was so
satisfying that it's a bit upsetting
that he didn't permanently pay for his
arrogance furthermore it's not like
there weren't other ways hercules could
have been introduced in the post-credits
scene it could have even happened during
a funeral or something for instance
one of the best parts of taiko itt's
directed films is how he manages to
carefully blend moments of drama with
comedy in the case of waititi's mcu thor
films he manages to blend in action and
fantasy as well when pulled off well
this blend of seemingly disparate genres
can be incredibly compelling for
audience members however that sort of
total dexterity is hard to pull off at
the best of times and even the greatest
filmmakers sometimes stumbled waititi is
no exception while most critics enjoyed
his previous thor film 2017's thor
ragnarok there were some fans who
criticized its overuse of comedy at the
expense of genuine emotion since thor
love and thunder deals with even heavier
subjects the margin of error is even
slimmer than ever before and according
to some fans ytt wasn't able to stick
the landing this time
in an interview with indie wire natalie
portman revealed there were whole
sequences planets characters and worlds
that didn't end up in the movie that
were hilarious and amazing and that we
spent a lot of time and energy on now
deleted scenes and abandoned plots
happen with every movie and co-writer
director taika waititi responded to a
potential white tt cut with some harsh
words he told nme i've been thinking
about director's cuts i've watched
director's cuts of a lot of other
directors they suck director's cuts are
not good directors need to be controlled
sometimes and if i was to say ah you
want to watch my director's cut it's
four and a half hours long it's not good
there's a lot of cup of tea breaks in
there but is that true were all the best
ideas shown on screen as we've mentioned
before there is a curious lack of actual
god butchering by the supposed poor the
god butcher furthermore extending the
run time would allow us to see more of
the marvel cosmos as well as tie up
loose ends with characters from previous
films those would include according to
christian bale jeff goldblum's
grandmaster and peter dinklage's dwarf
eatery heck why tt wouldn't even need to
necessarily add to the runtime he could
have called other plot lines possibly
shortening the kidnapping thread or
trimming the time spent with thor
hanging out with the guardians of the
galaxy this could have allowed more time
to let boar's arc breathe
after four phases of grand intertwined
storytelling the mc rightfully deserves
praise for its unprecedented success
especially compared to other would-be
franchises anyone remember the dark
universe i'm offering you a partnership
you evil incarnate me your good friend
eddie hyde however there is nonetheless
a large portion of the fanbase who feel
that the most recent slate of marvel
movies have been kind of rudderless and
this makes some sense as the previous
phases spent many years leading towards
the ultimate conflict with thanos and
the universe altering infinity stones
having such a clear end game in mind
meant that even weaker installments of
the mcu had a sense of purpose to be
fair phase 4 the mcu has seen an influx
of multiverse stories which seems to be
the new era's end game this started with
loki on disney plus later becoming a
main focus for the plots of spider-man
no way home doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and presumably the
upcoming ant-man quantum mania however
thor love and thunder didn't touch on
any of that at all now it's not like the
film had to address the multiverse
necessarily there are certainly some
fans who prefer stand-alone superhero
adventures existing alongside the
inevitable team-ups and crossovers still
it's a definite change from the tight
plotting that defined the earlier eras
of the mcu making love and thunder feel
somehow off
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you